en qué consiste la nueva de la nueva
doctrina y qué tanto puede crecer el
posicionamiento naval de rusia con ella
bien como explicaba recién que es una
doctrina fue aprobada por el presidente
de putin el día de hoy en el día en
conmemoración de el día de las fuerzas
navales y lo que busca es acrecentar la
imagen rusa en los mares del mundo no
por empezar
y
proteger la presencia rusa en
varias regiones hablando por un lado del
atlántico que eso
e incorporan lo que sería los mares y el
altico del mar negro el mar gasol y la
presencia en el pacífico que también hay
digamos rusia cuenta con el problema de
las islas kuriles con japón pero le
damos más que nada mucha importancia a
mejorar y proteger la ruta norte la ruta
norte no la ruta a través del océano
ártico para digamos controlar lo que
sería una posible ruta comercial entre
china y europa y usted menciona
precisamente el océano ártico que rusia
lo cataloga como de particular
importancia y por su parte washington ha
denunciado que los rusos intentan
militarizar esa zona cuéntenos qué puede
pasar entre eeuu y rusia con esta nueva
política naval
bien la política naval que propone rusia
busca incrementar y proteger su mar
interior la zona de control la zona de
control económico exclusivo que tiene
rusia a 200 millas de su frontera en el
norte que es la zona que puede mostrar
convertirse a medida que se aumenta la
temperatura global en la zona de
comercio importante y una ruta mucho más
corta entre europa y china que eso por
los mares del sur no entonces
principalmente van a aumentar su
potencia su
presencia militar en la zona pero a la
vez la doctrina hace hincapié en que
rusia tiene que mejorar su
armada digamos su fuerza naval pero en
cuanto a lo comercial no digamos
aumentar la mayor y mayor cantidad de
buques de transporte y buques
comerciales que hoy en día no tiene
tanta presencia y que si va a ser
necesario a futuro en especial a partir
de las funciones que cuenta
el gran problema que hay en el comercio
mundial es que los granos y la
producción rusa no pueden ser explotadas
porque efectivamente no hay barcos que
se dediquen a transportarla no esté por
las sanciones por la forma de pago por
los seguros y demás y otro de los puntos
de la política es que rusia busque
nuevas alianzas por ejemplo con india
irán irak o arabia saudita porque
importan esos países y cómo los nuevos
pactos se dibujaría en la geopolítica
bien efectivamente en esta doctrina
cuando habla de él el océano índico que
es el único océano en el cual rusia no
tiene una frontera
sin embargo establece que para esa zona
se va a promover posibles alianzas o
posibles
asociaciones con países como irán arabia
saudita india y esto tiene que ver con
todo el proceso que hay de
integración en eurasia no digamos estos
países son parte de la organización de
cooperación de shanghai son parte de
la unión económica euroasiática hallamos
es parte de todo este proceso de
reconexión interna dentro de eurasia y
por lo que la cooperación en el área
naval no sería de extrañar sino que
sería una forma más de
de graficar esta cooperación y además de
ser la zona donde hallamos presencia de
piratas no hay donde la relación ya hace
años que se da a partir de la lucha
contra y contra los piratas